I'm so very honored to be able to
announce the nominees in six of the
categories for the 51st annual Academy
of Country Music Awards which airs April
the 3rd on CBS you ready here we go
the nominees for new male vocalist of
the year are Brett Eldredge Chris
Janssen Thomas Rhett chase rice and
Chris Stapleton congratulations and the
nominees for a new female vocalist of
the year are Kelsea Ballerini am Nikki
guidance and Raylan for new vocal duo or
group of the year the Dhamma knees are a
thousand horses brothers Osbourne Maddie
and Tay Old Dominion and Parmelee and
for a video of the year the nominees are
biscuits Kacey Musgraves burning house
can girl crush Little Big Town
mr. misunderstood Eric Church and riser
Dierks Bentley the nominees were vocal
event of the year hangover tonight Gary
Allen featuring Chris Stapleton home
alone tonight Luke Bryan featuring Karen
Fairchild raise him up Keith Urban
featuring Eric Church smokin a drinkin
Miranda Lambert featuring a little big
town and wild child Kenny Chesney with
Grace Potter and the nominees for a
single record of the year our burning
house can buy me a boat Chris Janssen
die a happy man Thomas Rhett girl-crush
a little big town I'm coming over Chris
Young and take your time Sam hunt and
I'm gonna be there in Las Vegas to cover
all the awards for ET I cannot wait to
see who wins and congratulations to all
the nominees good luck everybody